hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to gravity cat now it's been
a while since I played a good
old-fashioned platformer and I don't
imagine that I've gotten any better at
it so let's just try and see what's
gonna happen when we hit play that's a
lot of levels holy [ __ ] so as with any
platformer oh it's got a story what a
beautiful day
scarcely I steal your blue homeboy yeah
what you stole its eyes I didn't know
that it was gonna be starting out like
that okay for the game need a plot Oh
so anyway gravity cat it's based on the
principle that you you flip with [ __ ]
you flip gravity upside down and at
least there's not a horrible spurt of
blood well off I go that into the
distance so it's damnit
at least yeah I mean I would have
expected with saw blades that there
would have been like an explosion of
blood after every single time that I
died but thankfully no and then he hit
lasers I guess is that ah because ah
[ __ ] ah him but I don't know what I'm
doing just yet and I'm embarrassing
myself and also it's very early in the
morning and I have no idea what I'm
doing oh hello
okay so this is basically the principle
of the entire game and I imagine that's
gonna get more and more complicated but
the reason that I saw it or the reason
that it caught my eye is because well
cats are adorable like gasps and for
some [ __ ] reason I was drawn to this
one because he looked cute or whatever I
don't need to justify myself to you Hawk
did exactly what I want to do what did
that do okay hey I damnit hip and it's
got pretty decent music if I have to say
so
so huzzah we're gonna keep going on and
on to try to steal back this cat's eyes
which is as good a plot device as
anything I've seen huh oh [ __ ] me then
god damnit this is gonna be harder than
I thought uh Jesus and the games got
like two game modes I got to remember
not to jump and actually use the gravity
okay alright
then yeah not entirely complicated up to
this point but I think I think I've got
a good handle on this yeah I just got a
think linking with gravity tada
okay hello man I'm getting super meat
boy vibes with these saw blades and all
this stuff which you know a lot wow [ __ ]
with a lot of people have been asking me
or ask me not lately ask me over the
years to play Super Meat Boy but a long
time ago and there's still like there's
a hidden other chance a weird revelation
to make for you guys to discover this
but there's like a hidden channel of
mine um that no one really knows about
anymore it's called markiplier
livestream highlights and it was a
channel that I paid just for like
highlighting live streams that I did
because way way way back in the day I
did live streams a lot more than I did
now and oh no it's called markiplier
live stream archives and it still exists
it's still out there I I don't know what
happened to it I haven't I don't even
know if that channel is like I'm able to
even log into it anymore not that it
matters um but yeah I played Super Meat
Boy a whole bunch on that and I played
like dayz and what is a weird revelation
after like announced a combine there's
there's hours of content I remember I
like I played um I played a man what's
it called max pain I played max pain I
played a whole bunch of Max Payne and I
tried to beat it on the hardest
difficulty and I did it and I believe
the archive is up there and I man just a
whole bunch of like old stuff man I
haven't even thought about that and
forever I need to go look that because I
completely forgot that exists I haven't
even given that a thought in years so if
I find it um I'll put a link in the
description because goddamn it's totally
blew my mind that even existed oh and by
the way this game is adorable and kind
of fun I will admit like the reason I'm
playing this is because I found it on
Steam and and drew me to it because
obviously happy cat visuals seem pretty
cool to me
but er than that you know I haven't
played like a difficult or challenging
platformer and this one is delightful
I mean this it's obviously not a lot to
uh shed its knob viously not a lot to it
but yeah there we go yeah yep philia but
it's pleasant poop [ __ ]
I [ __ ] yeah I can skill through this ah
what what happened what happened ah damn
it come on god damn it why do I keep
getting stuck on that corner let me go
through is that now I'm supposed to do
this
seems like I'm supposed to do this yep
nope can't do that
oh ah ah there we go okay then just jump
cuz I'm all gravity DUP
yep oh boy am I supposed to reverse
gravity here yep
dammit god dammit this sauce it's not
stupid I'm stupid because I don't know
how to play the game but HAP oh come on
there we go
yup okay get that go back over here pop
there we go okay we got it
alright now I'm getting it now I am the
smart hat yeah I mean the last time that
I played a puzzle platformer with
adorable cats like this was probably
bloody trap land and that one just has a
bit more death and destruction to it
which is more my flavor when I play
these games oh god I got to do this
again
ah oh my god don't do that to me that
one was actually challenging I mean I
know the whole point of this is to get
more and more challenging as time goes
on but you know sometimes I like the
easy route like not to think about what
I'm doing before I'm doing things and
also it's very early in the morning in
god dammit ah son of a [ __ ] yep ah what
we all would you okay okay hey yep okay
man listen this is actually kind of
hurting my brain I don't need to use
gravity all the time but I understand
that the main point of it is to use as a
gravity but I kind of remember goddamn
flipping up a side down like this like
I'm not a smart guy I'm I mean I was
used to gonna be an engineer or whatever
how am I supposed to
ah ah son of a tit
hush your face with the happy-go-lucky
music how am I supposed to do this damn
it
cuz I can't I can't reverse gravity in
midair I have to be touching the ground
to be able to reverse gravity ah I also
haven't pondered the conundrum of why
this cat is able to manipulate gravity
at will I mean I know cats are
mysterious and probably devilish and
horrible mysterious ways and from
another dimension but I don't know if
they'd be able to do all this mysterious
stuff they got here Eve [ __ ] dammit
God
[ __ ] and ass ah musics too happy for me
to be slightly frustrated at all this
not rayji yet I don't think this games
gonna give me the rayji levels but it
seems like there's a lot of precision
required which is a factor in these
platforming style [ __ ] games but
it's whatever god damn it how are you
supposed to be able to do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] man there's no other way
besides flipping right there but it's
it's it's overly precise maybe if I get
like right on the e oh [ __ ] me oh I'm
close why is this one so stupidly
precise and how is it supposed to get
more difficult from here yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] son of a biscuit god dammit it's
not that bad ah man god damn it it's not
that bad it's aa [ __ ] crime any
Christmas um I'm getting like physically
frustrated more than anything like ah oh
yes okay I'm done [ __ ] that man I don't
want to do any more with that it's too
early ah it's too early but either way
that is gravity caddie if you understand
the basic principle of gravity cat and
platformers you probably enjoy this one
it's it just seems like this one
requires a hefty amount of frickin
precision I needed to use gravity for
that I don't know why I didn't use
gravity for that I'm freaking fool if I
didn't use gravity for that it's
obviously gravity required and gravity
cat and that's what gravity means when
you gravity cannon your gravity
it's gonna be good in everything else
besides it's gonna fall into place and
you're gonna have a lot of fun playing
gravity cat I don't know
found it on Steam it was super duper
cheap I play it if you want there's a
lot of levels and whatnot oh this is how
this is gonna be Hey okay there we go
and boink well that one was much easier
than the last one okay so that's all for
gravity cat I'm just gonna let him die
repeatedly here and waste all of his
nine lives or however many lives he has
in this endeavor and also if I find my
old y Tube channel you can watch quite a
bit of content of old baby Marquis move
way back before I knew what I was doing
so I'm sorry for what you're about to
see but if I find it I'll put in the
link in the description below so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye
I guess this is a metaphor for a
threesome bloop bloop not for the
kitties